So far in this lesson, we've been working with equations involving exponents.
So now let's look at the other side of the coin, equations involving Logs. Have
you ever had a hearing test? Or maybe you felt an earthquake or seen a
hurricane. All of these things are measured using logs. At the end of the
section, we use the properties that you've learned about logs and the
techniques that we're going to discuss. To compare the intensity of two
different earthquakes. In the equations we're going to look at, the variable,
which is oftentimes going to be x, will be part of the input to the log
function. That means that to access is, we're going to need to use the inverse
of whatever log function we have, since that will undo what the log has done to
the x. So, what does that actually mean? Well, before, we were using each side
of our equation, as the input to a log function, because we had exponents. But
now, we're going to use each side as the input to the exponential function. So
let's actually do some work with this equation. Ln of x equals 10. What base do
you think will be best to use for our exponent, since of course, we want the
inverse of the natural log?